so again we've got you know
women especially especially famous women
in this case a nominally famous women
woman
telling their abortion stories in
response to rose so here's ireland
baldwin who's the daughter of famous
gunman alec baldwin telling her own
story um and she starts for some reason
talking about the time she was raped and
she she did not conceive a child during
the rape so that the rape had nothing to
do with
the abortion whatsoever but she starts
by talking about that and then
eventually she gets around to talking
about the time she actually conceived um
through consensual sex and then decided
to abort i want you to listen to the
reason that she gives listen
flash forward to another point in my
life when i did have a boyfriend and i
did become pregnant
at that point in time i would say we
were very unhappy together and
he made it pretty clear that he never
wanted kids or marriage um he barely
wanted to be in a serious relationship
i chose to get an abortion because i
know exactly what it felt like to be
born between two people who hated each
other
could i have had that baby and put that
baby up for adoption maybe maybe not but
choosing to raise a baby without my own
financial security
without a loving and supportive partner
that wasn't going to work for me
i chose me and i would choose me again
it's your life it's your choice
now this is great i mean the reasoning
everything you heard there is not great
but the fact that she's saying this
is great and um i want more feminists
and pro-abortion women
to be honest and uh and say this kind of
stuff out loud because people need to
hear it
you know the the vast majority vast vast
majority abortion in this country they
have nothing to do with rape nothing to
do with life of the mother anything like
that
uh these these very rare uh cases like
that is nothing it's just exactly what
you heard there um it's someone who
had consensual sex got pregnant and uh
you know could i put it up for adoption
yeah maybe maybe not
what do you mean maybe maybe of course
you could have put the child up for
adoption yeah yeah i just didn't feel
like it
i didn't feel like it but it's what she
said i i
didn't feel like
giving birth to the child
and going through the process put him up
for adoption and so uh you know just
killed the child because i chose me
and that is
the
pro-abortion argument
okay you you whittle everything else
away get rid of all the euphemisms
everything else all the talking points
all the propaganda
cut all of that
bs away and what you're left with is
exactly what you just heard there i
chose me
and there's
quite a bit of incoherence mixed in
because she also says well i i know what
it's like to be born uh to parents who
don't want me
okay well that's that's terrible that
you were born in that you were that you
lived in that situation as a child and
it sounds like your parents are pretty
awful in fact we know that they're awful
people
but
yeah but you're you're happy that you're
alive though right
so you were born into a terrible
situation
um
but you're still living i mean you
haven't you haven't killed yourself
thank god and so clearly you're happy to
be alive and not only are you happy to
be alive but you but your life is as you
attest your life is extremely important
in fact you believe that your life is
more important than anything else your
life is so important that it comes above
the life of your own child you could you
could kill your life according to you is
so important
that you could kill your own child just
to protect your own convenience and your
own lifestyle
and that is in spite of the fact
that you were
essentially as you say an unwanted child
tragically
so what does that tell us it tells us
that
even if a child is born into a situation
like this
they are still
worth
something they have
not worth something they have infinite
value because it's a human life
all the same
can't expect her to connect those dots
though
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there